tout le monde sait squeeze comme gens se
retrouvent pour aux excès salut non pas
trop fort non point concours parce qu'on
vient actuellement d'atteindre le
chiffre incroyable de 180 mille abonnés
et honnêtement ça se fait donc pour vous
remercier je voulais juste organisé un
petit concours bas symbolique on va dire
de ce que je vous dois en fait parce que
je vous dois beaucoup de choses
notamment ses 16 heures à passer sur ce
siège à dire les conneries et à me
marier pour vous faire marrer c'est
vraiment je trouve un échange incroyable
mons marcory vous tous vous et moi aussi
de mon côté donc vous inquiétez pas pour
ça c'est vraiment incroyable
encore une fois je vous remercie pour
tous vos messages qui sont négatifs ou
positifs quand s'est construit une expo
nerfs ça fait toujours plaisir
c'est toujours agréable pour essayer de
mieux avancer et se rendent compte de
comment les gens nous voient comment ils
voient nos vidéos ou quoi alors oui
parce que je dis tous vos messages
privés sur youtube tous les messages que
vous m'envoyez je les lis vont forcément
je réponds pas à tous parce que j'ai pas
la possibilité ça prendrait trop de
temps donc je réponds à ceux qui sont
vraiment que juste très très important
et croyez moi vos messages me font
vraiment plaisir surtout messages
d'encouragement et même les critiques
négatives j'essaie d'en tenir compte
quand s'argumente etc
c'est normal ça peut pas plaire ce qu'on
fait ça c'est obligé pas voilà tout ça
pour dire que vous êtes vraiment géniaux
m'aider beaucoup à avancer sur youtube
c'est une m'améliorer à tenir compte de
vos remarques et cgc de savoir si vous
voulez plus par exemple défi de squeeze
na qui vont revenir encore vu qu'il
s'était les vacances ne pouvait pas se
réunir avec lg z états puisque voilà
chacun partait son côté mais cette fois
on va revenir bon cac et les filets
squeeze et puis on va continuer cette
période manioc etc
vous proposez parfois des projets que
j'ai essayé de suivre ou quoi là par
exemple vous voulez absolument le retour
d un trouillard elle est basse et notées
çà noter vous inquiétez pas gênante en
cours des petits sujets qui me passe par
la tête comment parler avec mes potes
et puis bah ça va revenir vous inquiétez
pas pour ça et donc aujourd'hui je
décide de faire à mon troisième concours
donc le premier j'avais fait gagner que
nous console le deuxième j'avais fait
gagner trois jeux et celui là c'est le
troisième il y aura un peu plus de la
gagne et vous allez voir c'est parti
donc cette fois il y en fait cette clos
à gagner donc on va commencer par le
plus petit donc 4200 points microsoft
bon vous pouvez vous acheter des jeux
arcade ou un jeu ou une extension bon je
pense que c'est déjà ça ça fait toujours
plaisir d'avoir 4200 points gratuitement
ensuite à gagner trois jours choix donc
sur pc
xbox ps3 wii ps vita ou n'importe quelle
plateforme vous pourrez avoir un jeu
suffit que vous voulez et au sommet de
la liste troisième capture hd à gagner
de schepper médias donc qu'est-ce que
c'est le guen capture hd je pense que
vous connaissez tous et un boîtier
d'acquisition qui permet en fait de
capturer gbagbo gameplay c'est à dire
vos parties où s'aventurent dans les
jeux plus épiques les unes que les
autres à l'aide du boîtier donc on peut
le relier simplement un disque dur donc
ce qui est enfin ce qui facilite un peu
le capture vidéo enfin bon il y en a 3
gagnés ainsi que trois jeux ainsi qu'une
carte de 4200 points microsoft
j'espère en tout cas que ce concours
vous fait plaisir alors maintenant
comment participer bas c'est très simple
c'est un peu comme pour les concours de
youtube il faut vous soyez abonné à ma
chaîne que vous aimiez la vidéo youtube
rajoutiez dans vos favoris
je l'avais réfléchissez faire et de
laisser en commentaire donc le long que
vous voulez vous en choisissez un
et puis vous décider sachant que si vous
êtes tirés au sort après quelqu'un qui a
appris le lot vous vouliez qui en a plus
et par vous serez obligé de choisir un
autre lot le monde j'espère que ça vous
dérangera pas d'avoir par exemple le jeu
à la place d'un game capture bon même si
c'est un petit peu rageant c'est vrai
vous d'avoir les points à la place d'un
jeu enfin dans tous les cas vous serez
gagnant donc j'espère que ça vous plaira
en tout cas j'espère que ce petit
concours vous plaît bon j'ai pas les
moyens de faire un concours aussi gros
que celui diable x9 je m'en excuse mais
bon j'ai sur moi de faire ce que je fais
avec ce que j'ai eu depuis basse et un
peu l'intention qui compte on va dire
j'espère que ça vous plaira et je
souhaite bonne chance à tous et encore
merci
il est super médiateur